For the better part of two decades,
school improvement has been focused on
narrowing achievement gaps by boosting
the performance of low-achieving
students in reading and math. This
mission has undeniable merit, but it also
carries real costs. One cost is a lack of
attention to those students who are
hungry for learning that stretches
beyond the corners of state academic
standards. Another is that teachers feel
so obliged to focus on gap-closing
instruction that they feel far less
free to devote time and energy
to supporting advanced learning. When
students seek to master advanced math,
research historical essays, or plunge
into biochemistry, that should be
celebrated, not merely tolerated. As
William Fitzhugh, the founder of the
world's only journal for academic
research papers by high school students,
has pointedly put it: "We could at least
encourage the crazy ones."
So for 2019, here's a healthy resolution
for school improvement: Let's at least
make sure we're also encouraging the
passionate ones. How do you think schools
How do you think schools
can better support passionate students?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.